how did you find the story for
centigrade your movie
when you look it up online i don't see
an actual story
of the i see parts of stories that are
like that
is that something you pieced it together
or yeah so
i mean the original script was written
by a writer named daley nixon
um and i found his his
script on a site called inktip
um which i've you know had actually had
a
great success at finding things there
and and you know finding writers that
have never been
discovered or or have or been produced
and
um you know i came across his log line i
read i read the script and i was like
just really you know captured by this
story
uh and i did the same thing i i read i
went and i
started googling the um
you know the event and saying like i
can't find this event where i got on the
phone with him i was like look i love
the script um
you know what's the what story is it and
he said i go i found this man
this swedish uh man that you know
is that what it is he said yeah that was
based off of that story
um and then
that that inspired you know the the the
idea and the story and then he added
some other stories and then me and him
kind of talked and the more
that i you know as we went through like
the optioning process
the more i did research on
um you know people getting stuck in snow
people
driving on the side of the roads pulling
over getting stuck in snow
um i just saw it everywhere
um there's a film that was done
i think there was a story a very famous
story about a couple
and their baby being stuck in the snow
in 1989
uh i i should i should look up
that story before any of these uh
interviews but
uh it did it turned into a a kind of
shoddy tv movie but
it was a couple that was stuck in the
snow with their baby for
i don't know seven days or or three or
three days until they eventually the
husband walked off to
try to get help um there was a story
about a grandmother who was stuck on the
side of road for 10 days
there was a story about a woman who had
to give birth in her car
in the snow with her husband so
it just uh
you know it seemed like there was just
so many different stories that we could
kind of put in
as we kind of rewrote the script um
i doubt i tried to put in a lot more of
their kind of relationship
and and and deal with that with him with
uh
daily and um
you know the process of just kind of
finding
new you know taking this research and
these stories
and and having that's why we say
inspired by actual events because it is
it's inspired by
many different stories it's like an
amalgamation of different stories and
research and survival experts and you
know what you can't what you should do
and what you shouldn't do
you know i had a dp friend of mine that
read this
script and or or one of the many
versions of the script
and he mentioned um in montreal that
when you rent a car or when you drive in
the
in the mountains they tell you to keep a
candle in your in your glove box
because the heat of a candle will help
warm the inside of a car if you get
stuck
and so we were and then i you know
looked up
uh you know these these kind of packs
these survival packs that were in cars
um and uh
and it was true it was just such a you
know it was like okay this is a great
thing for them to
to to have and then what do you put in
that car and like how do you do it so
it was really taking it was taking uh
real stories
uh kind of meshing them all together and
you know doing the diligence of like
research and going and and
and you know how you deal how your
character should deal with this
situation
that kind of got us to centigrade
so you found the script on inktip and
then
you went and revised it yourself and
added different other elements to it
yeah i did it i mean daley and i passed
the script back and forth
um uh but yeah that's how
that's how it went i found out an inktip
um
i optioned the script from him um
we went back and forth on changes that i
wanted to do
i wrote you know scenes and changes that
weren't in there
um
and that that's that's pretty much how
that went
how long of a process was that once you
found it on inktip
and you thought you know what this would
be a great idea to do this and
and i'll kind of mold it in my own way
or do it in one scene you know one one
location
for the most part what was that process
like
like how long did it take to actually
get it to production
from the time you saw it on inktip well
uh
i wish i had an actual date for you um
i want to say that this script i mean
this script took off
faster i was i was in the middle of
pushing another script
at the time uh and i was in a meeting
with a production company
and they go and i was pushing
this boxing film that would that me and
my uh producing partner
bradley ross who was also the editor on
the film uh
we're pushing the this this project and
they go
yeah it's not really what we're looking
for like what else do you have we're
like
well we have this this other movie that
we just kind of started
uh it's about two it's about married
couple that's like stuck in their car in
the snow and uh
you know they pull over during a
snowstorm and like the whole thing kind
of takes place with them like stuck in
their car and they're
like that sounds great let's do that
um and you know funny enough that was
not even the company we ended up working
with
uh but we we saw it kind of take its own
inertia like it slowly started to like
we got it
we i started the writing process back
and forth but as we were writing
you know we started to slowly kind of
shop it around and get some interest
and we found uh fife in pictures molly
connors and amanda
bowers uh through a friend of mine
vincent morano who
eventually produced the movie with us
and they fell in love with it and it
kind of the film started to snowball
once we you know i hate using that term
uh with this film but once
molly and amanda you know and vincent
kind of came on with brad and myself
you know they kind of
you know molly was very great at kind of
like pushing and saying like
well let's just set a date to this like
can we do this now like how quickly can
we get this done i was like
well the script is pretty much done like
let's let's move this
for you know i can move that forward
fairly quickly and
she started to have me meet with actors
and send the
script out to people um as they went out
for financing and
i want to say that we met we probably i
want to say we met in like a
march and we shot in august
so it was pretty that that's
from my experience that's pretty fast um
to go from like
maybe we got the script in february or
january on inktip
and to be in production by august is
you know i can't i mean i can't haven't
been able to get anything else off the
ground that fast
um and it it you know
it it took on its own energy we you know
we found the people who you know we
found the investors that wanted to do it
the you know the producers kind of hit
the ground like raising the money
i was talking to actors trying to like
you know
feel actors out see who would you know
be into like the kind of
kind of not so normal or not so
the usual ways that we wanted to shoot
this
and we found you know vincent piazza and
genesis rodriguez
uh were you know vincent was somebody
that
molly connors had already known and
you know we had a great meeting and you
know they were completely on board and
you know and uh probably a month
probably a month or two after that we
were going into production
you